[Música]
olá boa tarde a todos
é um prazer enorme estar aqui fazer
parte deste painel de oradores você para
também ter esse projeto que é o telex
que é um gesto fantástico já devem ter
parado eu sou cozinheiro não é
lamento informar não vai haver comida
ocorre porém que não é comigo mas
qualquer das maneiras são cozinheiro
naquelas do tempo em que a cozinha ainda
não era propriamente aquilo que é hoje
ou seja não era pra mim era muito
interessante nos parar para a maioria
das pessoas ainda não era muito
interessante poder há cerca de 25 anos
mas um caminho novo para dizer que o que
eu tenho feito nestes últimos anos é
desenvolver algum conceito de enfrenta
um pouco diferente do que estamos
habituados a ver na cozinha tradicional
eu tenho tamanho carro que estará em
guimarães proprietário e chef de cozinha
dessa mesma mostrada durante o dia que
eu represento no qual o trabalho no dia
a dia não estará na cozinha alternativa
sobre maranhense ter parado
as transmissões pra mim isso é uma coisa
muito importante
agora se dá da guimarães a nossa cultura
a nossa gastronomia
as nossas festas como pinheiro com o
qual eu me identifico muito pra mim não
há aqui uma ligação muito forte entre 1º
e rojões por exemplo não podia deixar de
ser
sem dúvida que nós em guimarães que a
música pra não falar no vitória né
vitória é aquela coisa que está na alma
e não sabe e nunca saí sem dúvida que
morais é um povo único que vive
intensamente a algumas tradições e eu
não sou exceção da europa de marcha eu
levo animais no coração sempre foi pra
fora
e foi isso que eu fiz
anos foi iniciar minha carreira cá foi
aqui que eu comecei a trabalhar com
aquilo que eu deixe um espaço
literalmente todas as maneiras até as
vinte e poucos anos e pouco depois que
seria então um anseio um pouco de
liberdade foi que eu criei as minhas
raízes
os meus filhos juntamente com a mulher
que são verdadeiramente as minhas raízes
e foi que eu tire a investir o meu
capital humano na capital financeira
tamanhos agora neste projecto que é um
projeto que visa não só o lucro não está
muito claro que sempre tem que ser
rentável negócio que vale a pena se não
for rentável
nós temos aqui preocupações muito maior
e bastante interessante no que diz
respeito aos conceitos fez tão feliz mas
também como fez voltar eu demos anos por
fora da cidade usados por fora do país
sem dúvida que o sentimento de querer
voltar tava tamaki a negamos a mexer
comigo ia fazer é não pensar em projetos
como é como é que eu ia fazer para
conseguir ter carro gosta de tocar um
projeto dizem que convinha am
é uma forma de arte bom eu acho que a
cozinha é um mistura de arte
temos nós temos cores sabores e texturas
temos um sem número de coisas realmente
se parecem com arco e eu acho que é
considerado isso mas mais do que isso a
cozinha emoção eu acho que quando nós
conseguimos provocar emoção
uma pessoa quando ela está a comer um
prato que nós criamos um determinado
prato e sim caminhar pra mim faz sentido
é claro que a estética é parte
importantíssima hoje em dia é o primeiro
impacto que nós provocamos nas pessoas é
a parte estética pois bem e usarmos aí
as coisas e eu como quando estou neste
ano na conceptualização de um prato que
eu penso
em primeiro lugar em tentar me envolver
com o tema seja a natureza seja um
produtor seja um produto seja o que for
e por exemplo neste prato que é um prato
que nós fizemos o ano passado é que o
que eu imaginei e produz um teu foram as
memórias de quando eu era criança e
quando ia a a apanha por exemplo apanhar
um músico para fazermos o projeto e
ocultar o pinheiro para fazer usar natal
sem fome que é o temportal chineses e há
cerca de um ano a um ano e pouco e
otimismo com a minha filha exatamente
fazer isso ou seja essas memórias são
tamanhas valores que a gente vai passar
de geração e aquilo que eu senti quando
estava lá
foi aquela sensação de sentir as folhas
debaixo dos pés no chão e logo para
fazer ao utilizar um prato onde eu
pudesse transportar isso a ideia e
tornar o combustível está na ativa
o mesmo acontece quando nós o exemplo de
um produto da loja e que em determinada
altura nós temos excesso de produção
temos sete isso essa oferta
olhamos para um para um para um para uma
imagem da gente
eu tirei na casa da minha avó e penso
que a maioria das pessoas quando olhar
quando olha com a imagem destas pensa o
que vocês acham que está aqui o manual
nossas forças mas as coisas estão mais
ágil baseada em uma dura então é isso
que eu vejo aqui o que eu vejo
é um produto está terminou o seu ciclo
de vida mas que está com muito sabor que
está com com muita concentração de sabor
e aquilo que eu quero fazer é recuperar
os apanhar las e transformá los em minha
idéia como é que seria está avançar
quando ela estava no auge da sua vida
então logo começamos a pensar o que pode
fazer com uma banda que vamos encontrar
o produto
onde é que vamos fazer com qual é a
idéia que nós gostamos por aqui eu
comece a pensar naquilo que eu gosto eu
gosto mas as salas por exemplo digamos
pra mim é um caso em favor de como está
a lançar de agosto sabor mas não gosto
só o senhor então começamos a imaginar
que eu faço
sei lá vamos fazer um par fé fé é uma
vazão de sangue frio o usuário cavalos
no meio
usamos um puré de maçã assada temos lá
unimos visto chamas como as rotinas de
uma saveiro e depois nos amou imaginar
como por tiros nesta manhã que vai
vencer e vamos tirar lhe o sabor da
canela avançada em um sem número de
coisas que nos remetem para para um para
um produto que é tradicional para coisas
que não são muito próximos e que nós com
os quais nos identificamos isso não é só
os ministérios feito pelo produto
respeito o outro está o respeito também
à natureza respeitar pelo santos da
natureza por exemplo as estações as
estações a nós pessoalmente me inspiram
mim - e eu adoro a primavera eo outono
primavera porque aquela explosão de cor
do produto é uma coisa todos que
entrarem em nós e que nos obriga quase
criar outro lado gosto muito do outono
apesar de ser mais nostálgico é também
não é só um fim 5 virar realmente 1 25
mas se olharmos para o outro lado se
olharmos paixão - como mauro zacher
vemos frutos certo temos as hortas como
hortaliças as obras
raizo site do sul 77 tudo isso é
altamente inspirador e quando uma imagem
como esta que temos aqui
já pensou logo em tradição meta anual
para cristalizadas e eu gosto de estar
cansadas mas confesso que é uma coisa
que nos surpreenda que não tinha alma
que faça alguma maneira 04 que está na
sala que eu comi fantástica não eu gosto
mas aqui o que ocorre atualmente fácil é
começar a imaginar o que é que eu posso
fazer com essas questões até onde é que
eu posso explicar isto
e começa a pensar castanhas assadas são
martinho sa mantém castanhas e vinho e
jeropiga e certa e comece a pensar eu
tenho será que nos fazer humor isso
claro vamos pensar a usar uma massa fina
estampa larissa enfrentaram e inventaram
por isso vamos pegar na nascar nos
bairros exclusivas fazer um parto é um
prego o quiserem free geral vamos passar
aos quartos particulares branco na
pontinha para que o efeito do que está
ameaçada
vamos fazer um lado da voar vamos fazer
seu a jurupiga vamos fazer o que nós
fazemos rotina para se ter um caminho
para lá todos se diversificar e isto não
é só cozinha está a imposição de sanção
horas é situar em respeito por aquilo
que não se considera uma pessoa de
espírito livre e adoro o domínio de uma
pessoa sem dúvida para mim é uma das
regiões que mais interessante eu costumo
dizer que nós estamos em uma situação
geográfica
principalmente aqui mas muito favorável
nós estamos entre o mar ea montanha
estamos aqui temos peixes outro lado
temos ótimas carlos mas na verdade no
mínio a cozinha é incrível nunca mais
acaba
no entanto em mais um a um prato que não
se identificar
acaba a conquistar criaram aqui há uns
anos aqui não sei ao certo o que é que é
mas mesmo antes de ter ou estar aí eu
comecei a pensar o que é que nós
tínhamos há 30 anos atrás em guimarães e
toda a gente tinha algumas hortas na
verdade eu acho que eu lembro é tanta
gente morta
a gente tinha morta não plantava os seus
um chute tinha os pequenos umas pequenas
árvores de fruto e alface os copos latas
etc
e toda a gente assistia das suas
pequenas hortas e como se imaginar que
tipo de prata que eu podia fazer você
pensar ok mínimo você pensar na orça
quando a gente vai para cima daquela
terra fofinha que tu vai abaixo
os pés sempre que a gente vai andando e
pensei em fazer uma terra então ok quer
um sabor do reino
vou trabalhar com um pouco mais vou
ficar aqui nos comércios para depois não
precisa sair e fazer aqui uma coisa fofa
que pensei também ok tem de servir pra
mim tu vai ver vamos fazer aqui um manto
com grama alta com paul que também é uma
coisa muito tradicional pra nós com
ervas aromáticas
vamos cumprir isto e depois digitais
tatá hospitais é coisa que não falta
certo então isso também me incorporar
uma proteína a porque na altura toda a
gente tinha um box coisas
juntamos fez lembrar o prato em termos
nutricionais
olhando para a moda a cozinha está na
nova série toda a gente está de acordo
comigo ou seja basta atualizar vezes em
20 ou 30 programas por dia na cozinha
vamos o que acho que têm centenas de
gremistas
isso é uma coisa que nunca mais acaba no
entanto se olharmos para atualizar
principalmente atualizado às propostas
programas vemos nos carros como call
usina
no entanto nós cá
temos excluindo produtos incluindo
produtores e nós ficamos nessa minha até
porque é uma raça que na década dos anos
90 para extinta
é uma carga extraordinária muito boa e
que não tá da onu neste momento já que
não está valorizado ea ter alguma
aceitação e aquilo que nós queremos
fazer como como comércio do produto
fui na vida eu não concordo quando
criamos este prato o pão queijo prato
não está a pensar em ser eu a brigar
não queria ser a mulher eu queria que
fosse a cara você é a estrela então a
única coisa que a gente fez aqui foi um
cara morou e tocar tradição o
carro-conceito ar
o cara respeito pelo produto e juntá-lo
cor alegria porque isso faz parte da
nossa cozinha uma cozinha divertida uma
cozinha colorida mantém a dúvida também
aquilo que habitualmente faz recorrendo
a técnicas mais avançadas e neste caso
concreto foi elevar e valorizar o
produto que é esse que me interessava e
isso além de ser um uma inovação pois as
máquinas nos permitem ter um padrão de
qualidade constante
ou seja temos um ponto de cozedura
fantástico temos em tudo aquilo que é o
ponto em que a gente quer
conseguimos sem dúvida foi criar aqui
uma grande satisfação e surpreender as
pessoas querem que nos interessa é que
quando cremos prático o processo
criativo pode viver de imensa de
diversas formas da natureza posso dizer
que já pensei em pratos e já surgiram
idéias ouvir um concerto música não tem
necessariamente serão provou ser um
produtor de ser uma paisagem ser que
seja é é normal eu por exemplo entrar
numa horta começar a arrancar tudo ia
pro várias pessoas pensam esse tipo de
button na cabeça
mas eu gosto provável tendo provado as
coisas ou está numa praia começar a
apanhar aulas e começar a provar
faz parte da minha maneira de estar e
aquilo que eu queria transmitir é esse o
valor eu não acho que nós temos é o que
eu tenho um treinamento nos últimos anos
consegui caminhar por aí foi que isso
não é só a cozinha está em mãos a uma
tradição é é o valor do cheque é tudo
aquilo que diz respeito ao nosso povo e
aquilo que nós temos de melhor
obrigado a todos os brasileiros
[Música]
[Aplausos]